[Music]
all right let's go to gabriel in toronto
what's up gabriel
hey man i'm good how are you i'm
outstanding brother how we doing
yeah yeah i'm doing all right all right
man so what's up how can i help
yeah so uh
i would like to propose to my girlfriend
uh but when i spoke to her dad
sometime around march
he did not give me his blessing to take
her hand in marriage oh no he said no
yeah you said no um
dude and that was in march tell me how
that was
how did how did the conversation go
did this shock you or did you know this
was coming
no you know what i didn't know what to
expect
so i guess it kind of did shock me um i
just asked him like
yeah we know we've known each other for
this time and i have this much money
um and he's like oh yeah that that
amount can uh buy you a trip like just
buy you a flight ticket
basically said i have no money
um
i don't have an education um
and he just wants he said to chill for
five years
for five years
yeah that's what he told her yeah that's
what he told her all right so you
wow
uh i one day i gotta check with him and
make sure he's cool that i tell that
story one day i'll tell the story on the
show about when i asked my father-in-law
if i could marry his daughter it's
outstanding his response to me and by
outstanding like i still shiver but um
so you
this he just got outright no
so you called this dude did you call him
or did you go in person
please tell me i was in person nah so
she she lives in a different country so
i have to call him okay so you call him
and he just says no and then do you
circle back to her does she know this
exchange happened
yeah yeah
so so what does she say i'm out or
forget that guy oh gosh i mean she gets
pretty emotional about it well i would
imagine so
i'm kind of at a loss i haven't heard of
this happening very often um and so
does she want to still go through with
this thing i mean how can i help let me
let me say it that way
yeah yeah so
she does like she wants to
like she wants me to propose she wants
to get married
um but you know i always heard like
i i obviously i want to respect like her
dad's blessing i mean it's his daughter
right um but
uh so the kind of the problem is is that
she he
doesn't really treat uh her her family
the best
and she's she told me that he has like
um some narcissistic um
traits what's the culture right and
uh so he's nigerian okay um so a lot of
like i mean i'm not saying all nigerians
are like but it provides cultural
context there yeah
um yeah it's like a lot of pride um you
need to be stable have an education like
that's a must or else you're stupid
right
that's not just nigerian that's that's
many many many cultures right um so you
asked for this blessing you didn't get
it
and
were you really asking for it or were
you trying to
do the thing that you thought you were
supposed to do and then of course he was
going to say yes welcome to the family
or were you really asking
because if you were really asking he
said no
if you were doing it more as a romantic
gesture
and
now you got some input that you weren't
really asking for
um that's and that's a whole other track
so were you really asking or no
uh
i would have liked to have his blessing
before so i guess yes
okay
um
yeah but i asked it in march and then
now it's
now i'm gonna see her in september okay
um
so it's kind of like a while and i was
uh
i have her mom's blessing he said he
said five years man you've given it like
three months
yeah
so it's
not the greatest timeline so let's let's
back out for a second is he right okay
do you have no money
do you not have an education do you not
have her best interest in in mind
so i i don't i
i made a plan to not go to post
secondary go to entrepreneurship okay um
and are you actually purdue are you
actually pursuing entrepreneurship are
you just one of those guys that does a
lot of like googling
and you want to be like a
like
like a halfway day trader because i got
an idea and i got a lot of money in
bitcoin or are you actually working 130
hours a week to get a new small business
off the ground
um so
i have been but like not 130 hours or
whatever but i have like
a few businesses
but i was i wanted to start something
on the ground once i move
so i don't just start something here and
then have to leave you know um
you're not in school
you're not working you're
entrepreneuring why don't you just move
now and get going
because it's really hard to uh get a
permit uh get a visa
absolutely and if
yeah if we got married um it would just
i would get it instantly
still avoid that
man this whole thing's getting messier
by the second
yeah
so
how old are you
21 21.
do you want to marry this girl because
you love her or do you want to marry
this girl because she's going to
get you
located uh relocated faster
oh no because i love her how long have
you all been together i i wouldn't care
where where we went uh
about a year and a few months now what's
the rush
uh
i think we kind of just want to start
our life together i mean this is all
mutual by the way it's not just me like
wanting a visa wanting like other stuff
i know that that could sound bad
but yeah we just kind of want to start
our life together um you know start
living together
um
she's starting a business too so i'll
help her with hers
um
i guess we just want to
start our life you know
and he wants to move out of the house i
want to move out
yeah
ultimately
there's a couple things at play here and
some of this you're not asking me but
i'm telling you anyway
if you're gonna quote unquote commit to
a life of entrepreneurship
i can tell
by your
voice you're not there yet
because committing to a life of
entrepreneurship isn't just i got a
couple of businesses i'm starting i'm
just going to sell shoes on ebay
does that work yes there's a thing and
blah blah
be committed to an idea
to making this thing work
to adding value and good in the world
and dude that
that purpose that why that drive should
have you up before any of your neighbors
and should have you working way into the
night
in that there's an entrepreneurial ethos
when you're around real entrepreneurs
you can feel it on them
and it isn't something that you do to
avoid college or i got a couple ideas
man i'm just thinking about because i
know those guys too
and they're they're just wet blankets
they're just sad drippy
i don't do they just i'm like my
shoulders are egging up right now
does that make sense
and so if you're gonna commit to that
there will be a fire in you
like a fire yeah
and
that will make its way through the
telephone
that will be somebody that dads want you
around
right because you have a zest for life
you've got a zest for adding value to
other people
especially and foremost
that guy's daughter okay so you didn't
ask me about that
if i want you to hang up his phone and
sit down and actually say what do i want
to do
and it shouldn't like just sitting
around wait until you move or i want to
start get going today man get going
today and if you build up a bunch of
clients and then a year later you're
married and you're living in a new
country or a new town awesome the skills
you'll have learned now will translate
directly where you are whatever that
hustle is that grind is the how to get
funding is the hours where all of it
will will nothing will be a waste
nothing okay
so that's unsolicited as it comes to his
daughter is a simple simple thing
he said no
he said wait five years
and so y'all can either get married
no he he doesn't have his blessing
depending on who he is the cultural
implications where he lies in his family
all that stuff he may cut you out
forever
and if you are good with that then be
good with that
go into it with um with eyes wide open
or he may have been blowing smoke at you
just to see what kind of man you are
and you get married and he gets really
pissed off and then you really show him
how much you love his daughter
what kind of good you're adding to your
local community to her life to the world
to that family and then he comes around
and then in 5 or 10 or 15 or 20 years
this is a funny story that y'all tell at
you know at
religious holidays
um
or
you hold off that i mean that's what it
comes down to so is she willing to say
forget this guy i'm out of my dad's
house i'm moving out um i don't care
what he has to say i got my mom's
blessing that's good enough for me let's
get married
yep okay then what are you waiting for
something's holding you back uh
i mean i i'm planning to do it in
september so
uh not much has hold me back i just
wanted to get
some some wisdom and insight i guess
right
yeah at the end of the day she's not
property
she's her own person
yeah
and
dad said no
and it's gonna be hard
okay it'll be tough and so don't think
it's just gonna be this ah be all good
it may not
he may cut you all out
hopefully he doesn't
here's what i would do if i were you
okay here's what i would do
i ask my father-in-law
hey can i have your daughter's hand in
marriage and he said no you can't i
don't think you're i think you're a bum
i think you're lazy um i haven't seen
that you love her you're 21 you're a kid
you've only been dating her for a year
um
no y'all aren't ready for that
and then you that stings and you go back
to her and she gets upset and you're
upset
and then you decide you know what i'm
gonna do it anyway
four or five months later here's what i
would do out of respect
i would write him a letter
hand the written letter no i'd probably
type this one i'd type this one
i'd write him a letter
and say
i want you to know i've taken your words
into account and i'm grateful for your
perspective
here's the things that i'm doing
here's here's how i love your daughter
here's my commitments to your daughter
here's my commitments to your family i
am choosing to go forward and ask her to
marry me
i do have your wife's blessing i hope
that in time you and i can come together
and have a
great relationship i do understand that
i'm going forward
without your blessing
i hope to earn or i hope that you will
give me your blessing in time
and that way you are looking him back
you're like you i'd eye him and y'all
did over the phone but
you said can i have the most precious
thing in your world and he said no
and now what you're saying is i'm taking
it
and um i am going to join join um your
family
i am um not taking it cause you don't
own her either um
i am gonna co-create a world
together with your daughter
and i want you to know that i respect
you and i appreciate it your insight and
input and i hope that in time i can earn
your blessing
but i'm moving forward
and that way there's no secret there's
no hiding there's no you ducked into a
corner and just did this thing no you
stood back up
you have enough courage to override the
the blessing that you asked for that you
didn't get
um but you all need to have clear eyes
about what this relationship is going to
look like without dad he may not go to
the wedding he may not fund the wedding
he may tell all the brothers and sisters
y'all are forbidden to go and some of it
may not go all those things make sure
you have your eyes wide open please go
to a pre-marriage counselor talk about
this stuff
because it's gonna be hard on your wife
especially if she loves her and respects
her dad this is a hard um
rock and a hard play she's found herself
between right
so please go to premarital counseling
get some insight into this and best of
luck to you brother let me know how it
goes i am interested if you're gonna go
ahead and propose in the next month or
so and i guess when the show's come out
it'll be a bright about when you're
doing this let me know how it goes um
write me back and i'd love to hear about
um does he come around or does he cut
you all out or what happens next
but kudos to you for your bravery
brother stand up on both feet and look
him back in the eye and um take the high
road make sure he's got something to
hold in his hand